dark souls 2 recently you're not gonna
let me play dark souls 2 now are you
know we're just going to talk a little
bit about it because Justin we had some
big news on dark souls 2 earlier this
week they did they so from software is
going to be bringing the game to ps4 and
xbox one alright not probably not a huge
surprise I mean this has been a year of
remasters and and this is kind of the
perfect game to bring over I mean we've
had the last of us other good games room
writer Tomb Raider and dark souls 2 is
something that seems ripe for that kind
of experience because it did look better
on pc right Kevin when you were when you
played through the review uh yes it did
look better but not not significantly so
it was a matter of you know hey things
that a higher resolution look better but
it wasn't like a dramatic so this is
gonna be coming out as a version called
scholar of the first sin and it's going
to introduce new story there's going to
be a new and pc it's going to come as a
package game for xbox one ps4 and PC and
and 360 and ps3 like there will be a
package version and that's going to
collect all of the DLC so far so if you
haven't played it you'll still be able
to pick it up and play it on any console
you want if you play it on ps4 xbox one
or if you have a PC that'll support it
it's going to look a lot better they're
going to revamp the visuals revamp the
audio like the kind of stuff that you
expect from it's going to be directx 11
on pc yeah but if you've already played
it if you even if you already own the
game all of that story stuff is still
going to come to you you're still gonna
be able to play it through a free update
that's coming to the last gen versions
just not the production value stuff
right yeah yeah yes course all those
increased visuals and that's kinda stuff
and all the the bonus new content that
they sort of mention there they mention
the NPC they mentioned uh you know then
there's gonna is there's not going to be
like because it's not not deals using
pack in the sense that like the Lost
crowns or lost Kings what was that
program usually crown of the sunken King
yeah the bubbles lying yeah new in like
that that's all included in scholar the
first sin uh so what do you think like
is this a game you would Kevin you've
you've played dark souls 2 played a lot
of it but as a game you would attend go
back to over the weekend totally on next
gen con totally but I mean you know i
mean i think the original Dark Souls is
the best game of its generation you know
so
so I yeah definitely I would go back I'm
curious I mean we we know that there
will be upgrades and stuff like that but
that trailer does that doesn't do a very
good job of like really selling me is
like it yeah I'd love to take a look at
in a minute yeah it doesn't do a good
job on selling me on on having do that
but of course I would do that because I
love the games but I'm curious to know
whether you know this is now going to be
their chance because of course there was
the whole kerfuffle over the original
footage that they showed and how the
lighting changed like the lighting
became a lot flatter and the whole idea
of torches seemed really cool in the
beginning but it ended up being a real
missed opportunity in the actual game
partially because I suspect that did
they tone that stuff down because that
they couldn't get it to run very well
with that lighting model so I'm curious
now now that we get you know the better
that you know the more powerful consoles
does this mean now that they're actually
going to implement the old lighting
model and we might actually get to play
the Dark Souls 2 we sort of imagined it
would be like the dark souls 2 that they
showed with when we exactly the dark
souls 2 that they did show that that
then never became now obviously I think
dark souls 2 is excellent regardless but
you know I'm curious to see how this
would even change the game if suddenly
the you know the lighting was changed
and became more dynamic you actually
needed to carry around that torch yeah
our areas more perilous do you does you
know carrying around the torches of
logistical consideration that you have
to sort of work into your strategy right
you know do you do you approached areas
differently because of that or is it
just kind of like I could have a torch
and see a little better or maybe just
like bump the brightness up on my
monitor yeah that's ass I do sorry oh
yeah noni I'm gonna win a game start
every couple of brightness don't like
Dark Souls anyway why are you here I
don't not like Dark Souls I don't yeah I
just don't think it's fun it's sad that
it finally son of an elusive thing to
think it's trying to be in Dark Souls
that's that's try that's a problem for
me I don't think that this this version
is probably not going to introduce the
fun mode for people who like Nintendo
games do you like Mario Kart here's the
dark souls for you no probably not what
about scholar of the first
doesn't scream Nintendo to you I mean
what is it person first sin what is the
first sin nudity why don't know Edison
that is not nudity he's got to cover it
up a lot they're eating out it's because
they ate from the fruit of tree and
knowledge so now they have the knowledge
that it is shamed learning it eating's
fruit so otherwise they would have just
lived there lived their lives and happy
harmony so this dude has been studying
people eating through them I'm a little
scholar we've got a Dark Soul fanfiction
territory here right now I'm big
Christmas I wrap it up scholar the first
sin it's coming out in april of next
year april of next year so in 2015
that'll be a early 2015 title for us to
look forward to also the added benefit
of friend amaan was just lamenting the
fact that he got the dlc for dark souls
2 too late and the servers are not
populated anymore and so hopefully with
this new release maybe the DLC that has
gone sort of dormant on last gen
consoles will once again be revived and
you have people in there one thing
that's interesting well how this might
kind of fracture the pc crowd because
it's going to be a different experience
on directx 11 verses directx 9 is that
can also split up the pc guys like we
don't know that yet but i will get more
details on that as it gets closer to
launch i guess we'll check it out cool
guys
you